hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's now week ten in for tonight's
chapter two shenanigans each week we
look at the map we find those tiny map
changes alongside the huge ones and
record them here so sit back for ten
minutes
[ __ ] code a tomorrow in the for tonight
shop to keep the series going and let's
look over the last week in fortnight
spoiler alert hot watch returns the
biggest change is the addition of the
Christmas event a winter cabin a daily
reward can be chosen from the stack of
gifts here what did you pick I chose
this the Millennium Falcon wow it looks
so good let's start a list of the items
in each box let us know what you chose
today in the comments below
I bet 90% of people chose the Millennium
Falcon right around the shack you can
also unlock a daily mission but there's
also a few secrets in here too
clicking on the cuckoo opens up a music
section and if you look closely enough a
peeping banana can be found outside but
this is a map change video so let's
forget this and jump into the map
changes
[Music]
the biggest change this week is the move
towards Christmas if this doesn't get
you in the mood for Crimbo then you have
issues Mary Chrysler one and all have
you been keeping an eye on the Christmas
trees this year they didn't magically
appear in each town in location they
were transported there by vehicle over
the last seven days the location of each
truck has changed every day as I'm
saying this retail row has one lazy Lake
has one happy hamlet version two has one
salty springs has one two there's so
many and did you get close enough they
play a Christmas song which is pretty
cool
other flatbed trucks though aren't at
their locations just yet there's one
almost at the beach imagine that
Christmas beach party and there's also
one going towards Slurpee swamps we'll
check back in a few days to look at that
Christmas erection yes I got that
wording again I'm sorry all the
Christmas trees that were held at retail
roll have slowly vanished to be taken
away by vehicles and the shop nearby
while the store is now complete again
with music in sight I'm sure you've
noticed all the Christmas themed house
decorations popping up everywhere there
are so many that I just simply can't
cover them all so here's a quick look
and loads of them are the best ones but
right now we have more important things
to do take a look at this
[Music]
get your butt over to the log workshop
seven days ago this had a few updates
only one or two gifts scattered around
and a car arrived with nothing much to
look at and a truck to I believe this is
fortnight's version of the coca-cola
truck you know you see every Christmas
what do you think it must be right well
fast forward seven days and now look at
this place
presents everywhere outside the car is
now packed to the brim with gifts and we
now know who makes Santa's presents it's
the gingerbread grumpy men man they are
grumpy and check out the bathroom nearby
I have no jokes to go here you'll have
to do the honors but things get freakier
here check near the pallets just behind
the truck
[Music]
what the hell is this monstrosity a bear
crossed with a child's doll Merry
Christmas
here's my guess this is foreshadowing
the helmet mask thing on the cuddle team
leader being removable soon like a new
style from here at the lock shop move
over to the west and you'll see a
catastrophe
one of the Cola trucks has fallen and
can't get up it's Christmas Bali is
strewn everywhere oh the humanity if you
get the chance look around here we have
a Metal Gear Solid bear with an eyepatch
one is also hiding behind a rock and
there's another one of those bare human
hybrids in the upturn truck what on
earth could have happened here let me
know your thoughts
as the snow falls I thought I'd check on
the trees at the nursery
they're now covered in snow but only the
large trees have grown at all in the
last few weeks but with all the
Christmas trees around the island new
trees need to be planted kind of like
our real world
hashtag team trees here's a really small
update but if you like Easter eggs
you'll love this one remember at the
start of the season I went through loads
of Easter eggs found in Chapter two
like the Homer Simpson Donuts well
here's something I told you back then
there's a couple of throwaway references
to films on the island you have to have
a look at - has anyone seen the film
Ferris Bueller's Day Off I know I know
that film is older than time itself well
the home of Pharisees friend is
recreated in fortnight in Section a4 in
the film they steal a red Ferrari and
when they return it it accidentally
drops out of the glass garage and down a
cliff edge tough break
when was that film made anywhere 1986
what well going back this week and our
prediction has come true the red Ferrari
has plummeted over the cliff just like
in the movie Ferris Bueller's Day Off
ask you Mom and Dad about it it's a
great film ok
[Music]
so now two things I missed in last
week's Meetup you guys were awesome and
let me know both on discard and via
Twitter at Adam grenade by the way the
first thing was the bush face just
outside pleasant Park this is a brand
new and very real landmark in the game
which could grow into something else by
the looks of it it's the gingerbread
face in bush form well spotted if you
found this let's keep an eye on this in
future weeks here's a huge one I missed
a freaking igloo made for a gingerbread
man in my defense in my game this did
not appear at all so I'm very thankful
that you guys found it
the place itself is pretty damn boring
but the gingerbread man on top is iconic
[Music]
have you been to the docks this week
remember back in chapter 1 there was a
chair house well over in the docks those
chairs have made it out of the
containers and are now ready to move
away from the docks on a long journey so
here's my question
where will these end up where will be
the new chair house in chapter 2 like
always if you see anything move during
the week
give me a shout and I'll make sure it's
in next week's video up in the mountains
we have a new dance cabin in the snow
it's a pretty cool drop point did you
know though that whilst dancing to the
djs tunes you can change the song by
simply hitting the decks or the speakers
it's the little things that make fart
night great and this is definitely one
of them great touch epic deaths I salute
you so the only thing left to cover now
is the Star Wars event did you get in in
time I really hope so
did you notice one huge thing during the
event hot watch returned
[Music]
okay I'll come clean someone built this
in my lobby but it was such a good touch
I had to say something about it after
the event we could see the crashed TIE
fighters around the map but how did they
get there
the event itself was pretty epic from my
point of view here's the best bits from
my experience I'll have to change some
of the audio because of Disney copyright
issues but if you missed it here's some
of the good bits ten minutes away beach
scene from Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker and JJ Abrams live in
fortnight wheels to you in just a few
minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so there we have it what did I miss
thank you so much for your time and as
always he is the legend roll call these
people have been kind enough to use my
code in the fortnight shop which funds
this series directly so thank you so
much many of you have supported me for
over a year now my mind is blown I'm
completely in awe and I thank you so
much so if I missed anything let me know
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade you
can get me on Twitter at Adam grenade
it's been a pleasure hope you enjoy your
winter break I hope you enjoy Christmas
if you celebrate it and I'll see you
after the next update merry Chrysler
very resinous merry Chrysler
[Music]